the search for a gunman who killed a
Baltimore police officer is entering its
ninth day 18 year police veteran Sean
Souter was gunned down in a vacant lot
he was shot the day before he was
expected to testify in a high-profile
corruption case involving other
Baltimore police officers Kris Van
Cleave is in Washington Chris good
morning good morning police continue to
believe detective Souter was the victim
of a random attack while investigating a
murder in a neighborhood prone to
violence but after nine days in a
citywide manhunt they are yet to name a
suspect and the lack of developments has
heightened interest in suder's grand
jury testimony Baltimore Police have
asked the FBI to enhanced this audio
from detective Shawn suitors final radio
call it's unintelligible right now we
don't know exactly what he said but he
was clearly in distress on Wednesday
police confirm signs of a struggle were
found on suitors clothing and the
veteran officer was shot in the head at
close range with his own weapon another
revelation came when investigators
confirm suiter was shot the day before
he was supposed to testify in a federal
racketeering case involving eight
members of an elite ball temor police
unit called the gun trace task force
they are now facing charges of stealing
money property and narcotics from
civilians over a two-year period well I
understand that the the wild
possibilities that go through people's
minds when we all want answers I just am
determined to keep following the
evidence there's nothing that we won't
consider the main witness to suder's
murder is his partner he told police
Souter approached a man acting
suspicious investigators say video shows
his partner took cover after hearing
gunfire location the shooting spawned a
citywide manhunt that put a Baltimore
neighborhood on lockdown at the scene of
the shooting some residents are offering
their prayers he deserve that prayer the
family deserved that prayer our city of
Baltimore
the career the reward being offered for
information about the detectives murder
now stands at over three hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars a funeral for
the father of five is scheduled for next
Wednesday
Vlad alright Chris thank you very much